welcome back it is 6 13 for a fifth
straight season big three basketball is
back you can catch some of the action
right here on channel eight starting
this weekend
joining us to talk about it and a
special all-star game hip-hop mega
superstar actor raider super founder and
of course the co-founder of the big
three league himself ice cube thank you
so much for being on the show this
morning how are you doing good morning
how are you doing i'm good how you
feeling i am feeling well i have to ask
you because you're here on good day las
vegas ice cube is today a good day
today is definitely a good day
i am so glad to hear that hey we're
talking big three for folks who don't
know exactly what big three is can you
fill us in really quick about what this
league is that you've created five years
now
well i mean everybody that uh
that has played basketball or or have
checked out basketball have seen three
on three
it's usually regulated to pick up games
and playgrounds but we've elevated it to
the professional level and that's where
you get the big three
and of course folks can watch it here on
cbs this weekend
and something that you've done here
recently that's pretty cool is that
everyday folks like me can actually take
ownership in these teams and and there's
12 teams is that is that right
yeah 12 teams you know we offered uh
ownership this year
uh through nfts
um
we recreated and reimagined the nft we
we call it a feat which is a forever
experience action token
which means that
you know you can you know definitely get
owner-like uh
benefits uh from these tokens and we
just think it's cool a cool way to to
get fans a little closer to the league
uh have fans to have you know bigger
stakes you know why be a fan when you
could be an owner well yeah no kidding i
mean if you're not good enough to play
you might as well be an owner that that
is so great now any changes for the
upcoming season
well i mean we we had some great changes
last year as far as to the rules we
brought in bring the fire which is a
one-on-one you know to to solve any
fouls that happen
um
so we don't want to tinker with the game
too much we just brought in great
players uh gerald green's joining the
league michael beasley cory brewer um
you know we still got our two-time mvp
joe johnson
so you know we just uh want to do
everything better than we did last year
we don't want to tinker with the game
too much we feel like people love it um
the first one the 50 win
you get three games
in the same time as you can get one nba
game in so
it's just uh to me
uh it's kind of calibrated perfectly
it's fast action a lot of fun ice cube
thank you so much for being on good day
this morning hey folks at home tickets
and information big3.com
ice cube thank you have yourself a good
day
you too take it easy